au cinéma camping est en train de
réaliser ce qu'on appelle un carton vous
êtes déjà plus de 3 millions à être
allés voir le film certaines répliques
sont devenues cultes et les fans
n'hésitent pas à se rendre sur les lieux
du tournage dans le camping de la teste
de buch en gironde où une partie du
décor a été conservé ce n'est pas les
flots bleus mais le camping de la dune
promis les visiteurs ne seront pas
obligées de porter le maillot de bain de
franck dubosc reportage francis mazoyer
philippe duval dune du pilat bassin
d'arcachon et camping des flots bleus un
nouveau circuit touristique à la mode
depuis l'énorme succès du film camping
le décor est toujours là un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les nombreux fans du
film
le camping est que c'était génial et
puis on a aimé franck dubosc et voilà
une petite photo souvenir tout à fait
pour moi
tu t'appelles sheraton chaque patrick
chirac
des répliques qui fusent un peu comme
dans les bronzés ces deux étudiants
bordelais ont apprécié au point de se
concocter un petit week end au camping
de la dune rebaptisé flots bleus sur les
traces de franck dubosc
tente maréchal 4 passes adultes de place
enfant est magnifique tente trois places
avec les jets au vent pour pouvoir
mettre les chaussures dans ce roman à la
réception en surf sur la vague camping
réservation est question sur le tournage
vont de pair nous n'avons pas encore
l'atteinte de patrick mai remettre une
facture sur l'emplacement 1,20 en est
fier ça s'est passé chez nous on joue la
carte du film à fond c'est
extraordinaire le directeur se frotte
les mains la fréquentation cette année
devraient augmenter d'au moins 20% son
camping il veut en faire une sorte de
musée pour touristes férus du film
va y avoir un parcours fléché pour tous
tous les lieux de tournage il va y avoir
des photos et planches de photos puis un
diaporama et on va leur expliquer permis
aux normands de très grands ça s'est
passé après tout ça c'est sur le camping
va faire de nouveaux adeptes mais
attention il faut savoir monter
l'attenté aussi danser lors de soirées
endiablées le style avec des tongs n'est
pas donné à tout le monde
[Musique]